my name is ethan hawk mecca maui i'm
oscar isaac and this is marvel cinematic
universe trivia quiz
all right first in iron man what is the
famous rock song that plays at the
beginning when tony is riding with the
soldiers okay do you guys remember the
beginning when he's right i do and he's
drinking i do and all i can remember my
brother used to open every day with
cranking back in black
i feel like tonally that makes the most
sense i'm not sure what it is but i know
it should be back and forth
all right back in black is our answer
we're starting back in black by ac dc
this iconic gay dc tune plays at the
beginning of iron man and spider-man far
from home happy plays this song again
and peter thinks it's a zeppelin song
all right so far one for one in the
avengers which avenger does loki mind
control for most of the movie is it
steve rogers clint barton blue spanner
or natasha romanoff well that one is
pretty obvious and i think you should i
should answer it
let's see who this is steve rogers i
think i'm gonna go with clint i think
it's clint all right you guys go with
clint i'm gonna go steve rogers ready
bye wrong clip
okay in the beginning the avengers lucky
uses the scepter to brainwash clint
barton and eric selvig before escaping
the cure i never saw that movie well i
saw that one and that's how it goes i
just remember i did see it i just didn't
know and guardians of the galaxy rocket
asks for three things when they are
trying to escape prison which is not one
of those things a battery a guard's
security band a prosthetic leg a jump
rope he would definitely ask for a leg
yeah prosthetically yeah yeah i'm going
to have to say
is it jump rope sure let's see say jump
rope yeah whoo you're great
true or false spider-man and black widow
are both on team iron man in captain
america civil war spider-man really it's
spiderman i'm gonna say true yeah all
right
i agree true 5050 baby okay in thor
ragnarok we notably meet korg for the
first time who voices him taika not
pedro pascal my space sister not stanley
i think it's gotta be tight
in avengers infinity war which of these
characters does get dusted by thanos
snap
black panther nebula thor peppa poppets
black panthers like panther yeah i think
it's black panther
yep yep we're kicking ass don't yeah i
mean i feel like we're not getting any
support from you
this is a triumph here i mean we're just
like marching through this we need some
feedback because we need some feedback
okay in one division agatha reveals that
wanda uses what kind of magic dark
dimension magic chaos magic asgardian
magic mirror dimension magic none of
these really ring the definitive bell in
my brain you know what's what is
interesting same color magic as arthur
harris i know it seems like chaos magic
but then also our tagline has embraced
the chaos so do you think i think dark
dimension let's go i'm gonna go chaos
all right mae's the winner that's a
slipper on marvel's party i feel like
they need to go back and fix one of
these they got a fixed point yeah yeah
all right finally in hawkeye when elena
breaks into kate's apartment what does
she make fun of kate still sleeps with a
stuffed animal that kate's favorite
avenger is hawkeye that kate never
learned how to whistle that kate only
owns one real fork i'm going with the
stuffed animal because she goes in and
eats pasta remember she does i think
it's the fourth yeah so it must be the
fork yeah let's go for it
six out of eight correct for me pretty
good i think you guys got all of them
did you no oh i got one oh my god for
sure and i cheated a little bit because
like you're one of the biggest fans
around
what can i say you're a massive mcu fan
not only have you seen every movie and
tv show more than once
but you remember all the small and big
details well we also have two friends to
help us out it's true we did it together
you just excel
thanks buzzfeed and make sure to watch
moon night
[Music]
you